oh boy hula is the language of the heart
and therefore the heartbeat of the
Hawaiian people and we tell our dancers
everything needs to dance your hair your
toenail your eyelashes it needs to dance
now you only owe a kahi hey you know
within three days the competition
tickets are sold out those tickets are
like gold they only bring the best of
the best and so we're very honored to be
able to participate the most prestigious
part of Merrie Monarch is the missile of
hula competition which is the women's
solo competition twelve hollows are
allowed to choose their very best dancer
our contestant this year is chemical any
car data you can you Lenny is a
professional hula dancer and we chose
her for many different reasons we wanted
her to cool not just a dancer but as a
person you are Pele any appeal and you
had no compelling Naoki appeal any cocoa
hot on one of my favorite parts about
Merrie Monarch week is that we go to
killer whale to pay respects to Pele
with a fire goddess I got a subscription
and it really puts into perspective
where you are in this world and in this
hula journey
I've wanted to be in Mary marks since I
was a little kid there was a lot of
times where I thought I would never it
would never happen for me but pretty
much most of my hula journey has been
working towards this moment which is
tomorrow professionally I've been doing
it since 2009 there's a difference
between dancing hula and Hollow and
dancing hula professionally
dancing furnitures is like American
Chinese and not the authentic Chinese
food and hotels here's what you'll see
beautiful men and women brightly colored
hair pieces and leis which are all
plastic but you won't see the skill you
won't see the love that you would at the
Merrie Monarch festival for Merrie
Monarch we practice every day for I
would say 3 to 4 months they're intense
can we try - and one more time what you
guys waiting invitation you need one
invitation come on you guys get your
head game on the biggest misconception
about hula I said it's easy all the
dancers and you quote me on this have
bad knees all of them so when you see a
beautiful hula dancer it's gliding
across the stage she's hurting she's
hurting really bad because nobody walks
around with bent knees you know six
inches off the ground blisters you get
blisters on your feet every single part
of your body needs to work you should be
gasping for air but you can
you need to look exactly the same as
when you first started if you can bend
your knees and swing your hips and have
this upper body carriage that's really
operate but make it look effortless
that's a Chu nation ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this allahu la competición
Cayley could use be ha if I gave the
performance of a lifetime if I gave
everything I had to that one performance
those 14 minutes up there just me I've
already won
you're just a vessel for all of these
people that came before you for all the
knowledge that you have and it's your
responsibility to share that it's your
responsibility to perpetuate but it
would be so nice to hear my name being
called and now ladies and gentleman it's
a little up for 2016
Kaylee
you know I don't dance hula just to be a
missile Ola I do it because I just
because I love it and I can't explain to
why I do I think I think it's something
you're just